these demonstrators are protesting
against a un peacekeeping mission that
they say has failed to bring peace
gathered in mali's capital bamako they
hold signs calling for the U.N Mission
known as Minutemen to get out of the
country
it's an evil force that needs to leave
our land it's been of no use it has
failed to deliver give us a few weeks
and we will drive them out of the
country
ten years ago Malian celebrated the
arrival of the U.N peacekeeping Force
now they say U.N soldiers are not the
solution but the problem they blame it
of failing to protect the population and
worse of not intervening as massacres
were carried out near U.N compounds
thousands have been killed from attacks
by armed groups linked to isil and
al-Qaeda in an interview with Al Jazeera
prime minister sugar Mica said the U.N
mandate isn't working
the International Community became
involved in Mali following the adoption
of a U.N resolution in 2013. Mullins
understood that it was to bring an end
to the war but as soon as the LGs peace
Accord was signed the resolution changed
to say they weren't here to end the war
but to protect the peace but there is no
peace
demonstrators wave Russian Flags mali's
military has sought the help of Russian
mercenaries from the Wagner group un's
independent human rights investigators
accused them of arbitrary killings and
torture in what Rights group describe as
possible evidence of war crimes
the work of the peacekeeping mission is
essential also with this humanitarian
support it brings a level of
accountability stability and protection
especially for those displaced
over 300 U.N peacekeepers have lost
their lives in mountain with more than
14 000 troops on the ground the U.N
mission is the biggest costliest and
deadliest operation in the
organization's history the demonstrators
have the support of mali's military
Junta and they blame the deteriorating
security situation not on the Army but
on the U.N but outside the capital in
the Northern and Central parts of the
country where the government is absent
millions of malians are dependent on the
un's mission to survive and provide
security Nicholas Hawk Al Jazeera